[Music]
hello everyone my name is nori and i'm
writing these one to two minute long
pieces for the little keyboard that i
have
this week i wrote a fugue thank you to
eric and rhys for submitting this idea
on instagram
[Music]
first of all here's the subject
[Music]
it almost sounds like a family of
chipmunks
they're going somewhere
this fugue has three voices and i used a
few traditional devices to transform the
subject in different ways
these include the inversion
the retrograde
[Music]
and the retrograde inversion
by the way thank you to everyone who
contributed with an idea for what to
base these pieces on i compiled them in
a list and i'll make sure to go through
as many as i can in the next coming
weeks
[Music]
the challenging part of writing a few is
to have all the different voices
complement each other while maintaining
independence this is also what generally
makes fugu sound complex and layered
[Music]
and now here's the piece
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
so i hope you enjoy that thank you so
much for watching and please share with
me any ideas or requests you have for
these little pieces subscribe if you
haven't already and i'll see you in the
next video
[Music]
you